le département et antenne réunion vous
présente bien social
[Musique]
la réunion est un vivier de jeunes
talents sportifs
certains d'entre eux ont même rayonner
notre île au niveau international pour
accompagner ces sportifs de haut niveau
dès le plus jeune âge le département
possède un panel dead et d'action
matthieu dafreville a remporté plusieurs
titres en judo il nous raconte son
parcours
[Musique]
c'est une journée dédiée au sport et à
la jeunesse à l'étang du gol à saint
louis
ils sont venus de toute l'île pour
s'affronter lors du challenge sportif
départemental des collèges
[Musique]
cet événement a pour but de promouvoir
la pratique sportive et pourquoi pas
réveiller des talents cachés
pas mal de jeunes ici très fort et je
suis sûr que parmi ces jeunes qui sont
ici aujourd'hui
il y aura pas mal de jeunes aussi qui
vont trouver leur chemin
et bien sûr il y en a qui sortent du lot
on sera toujours là pour les accompagner
lui est clairement sorti du lot et a été
accompagné par le département
matthieu daffreville est un judoka
réunionnais qui a raflé plusieurs titres
de champion aujourd'hui il est l'un des
parrains de la manifestation
je suis fier et honoré de devenir
aujourd'hui quand j'étais collégien
je n'avais pas eu la chance d'avoir un
événement aussi important de pouvoir
être confronté à d'autres collèges font
que c'est un super événement essaye de
lui montrer l'exemple mais qui à
l'occasion de pouvoir communiquer
partager avec les jeunes et les moins
jeunes
eh ben je le fais avec plaisir
originaire du tampon matures entre tous
les week-ends au domicile familial alors
bienvenue chez moi je vous emmène dans
mon petit coin un petit coin que deux
réunionnais a retrouvé il y à peine un
an après 17 années passées en métropole
c'est ici que sont conservés les plus
beaux souvenirs de sa carrière sportive
sa médaille représente le salue comme à
paris c'est le tournoi le plus grand le
plus costaud au monde
c'était en 2009 et voilà j'ai réussi à
battre démaquiller tepa mots mais
j'étais au max de ma forme et je suis
fier de ça parce que j'ai un moment que
les sportifs a pu partager avec ses
proches
car chez les dafreville le judo c'est
une histoire de famille et c'est sous
l'impulsion de son père que mathieu
commence la pratique à l'âge de
cinquante jours on m'a dit ça y est à la
hauteur du judo j'étais à fond je
faisais tout exactement comme mon grand
frère
et c'est comme ça que tous les dons
jeunes épanouis dans le sport et voilà
le fait de faire tomber sans donner de
coups à l'écouté pour nous c'était
quelque chose de ça et de cool donc
encore très vite le tamponnais se
démarque et intègre le creps de saint
denis avant de s'envoler vers la
métropole
à 18 ans j'ai fait le choix de partir on
m'avait repéré parce que j'étais
champion de france junior et donc j'ai
décidé d'aller au sport-études de
brétigny apparu un déchirement pour le
jeune champion qui est très proche de sa
famille pour les accompagner dans cette
épreuve m'a tuer ses parents ont pu
bénéficier de l'aide du département
il ya des possibilités d'avoir des
billets gratuits une fois par an s'il
était magnifique déjà pour pouvoir au
bras la femme une fois par an et on
avait aussi une belle prime le sait fut
condammé une belle prime d'installation
pour nous aider à
avant aussi à s'installer justement
c'est ça qui m'a aidé au début d'une
période très dure pour moi les cinq
premières années en métropole mais c'est
un peu grâce à ça que j'ai pu forger un
peu un mental pour aller plus loin
par la suite et la suite c'est une
formation à l'insep cinq titres de
champion de france un titre de champion
du monde universitaire et une
participation aux jeux olympiques de
pékin en 2008
un parcours avec des hauts et des bas et
une expérience qui a marqué le
réunionnais au delà du domaine sportif
et autant que les horaires souvent suite
des limites et nous comme toi tu donnes
est allé au delà des murs voilà en ce
moment une force qui l'a aidé à mener
d'autres combats entre la perte d'un
frère et la reprise des études pour
devenir kinésithérapeute mathieu ne
lâche rien aujourd'hui il exerce en
cabinet à saint denis et gardent en
mémoire son dernier coup d'éclat sa
victoire aux jeux des îles en 2015 en
l'honneur de son frère pour permettre
aux sportifs réunionnais de s'exporter
au niveau national et international
le département a mis en place plusieurs
raids les bourses départementales allant
de 650 à 1220 euros par trimestre
la prise en charge billet d'avion pour
des stages ou de compétitions nationales
ou internationales et l'aide à la
performance qui récompense le sportif
qui décrochent des titres sur le podium
en 2010 7 414 sportifs ont bénéficié de
ce dispositif dead 2 145 athlètes ont
été récompensés par le département pour
un total de 349 podium
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.defirh.fr 4 point fr lien social
accompagne les réunionnais pour la
mobilité
je m'appelle laisse vie valmy j'ai 31
ans je suis arrivé il ya un peu plus
d'un an j'avais le 17 mars 2016 la
famille vient de saint louis
je travaille chez arcelormittal et en
faire mon métier c'est une usine heures
pour le coup j'ai un poste de rectifier
à mon rôle c'est de réfuter quasiment
tout le matériel de coupe de lusine dans
l'atelier où je suis je suis la première
fille très très très fier très fier
d'être la première alors avant de
revenir gt gt bénéficiaires du rsa et
j'étais employée par une boîte d'intérim
j'essayais de me débrouiller comme je
pouvais presque je dirais congrès on ne
fait pas tout à fait mais très épanouie
en tout cas je touche du doigt ce que
j'ai longtemps espèces
[Musique]